si la machine désormais bien trop forte
pour l'homme aux échecs il existe encore
quelques failles dans son raisonnement à
part bien sûr vous êtes équipés d'un
super ordinateur en voici une
illustration rigolote dans cette
position la barre d'évaluation de
Chess.com n'en avantage décisif de plus
5 au noir alors qu'il existe pourtant un
moyen de forcer la nul avec les blancs
tout commence par un très joli fou à
catéchèques on vient sacrifier notre fou
pour attirer le roi adverse sur les
cases blanches et permettre une
succession d'échecs avec nos pions et
construire ainsi une magnifique chaîne
de pions tout est forcé le Roi capte sur
le fou et la maman crucial on vient
consolider notre forteresse avec F5 tout
nos pions sont sur casse blanche et il
n'existe aucun moyen pour les noirs de
pénétrer notre position ils n'ont pas de
cavalier pour sauter par-dessus ni de
pièces susceptibles de toucher les cases
blanches pourtant l'ordinateur donne une
évaluation de plus 7,8 au noir alors
qu'il est impossible de progresser